credo che tra tutti i videogiochi che io
io non ho fatti tanti e di videogames
ultimamente ma che credo che questo sia
il menù più bello della storia non c'è
un cazzo presenter voler buchi jobs ker
mansion degli attenti ragazzi e
benvenuto che subito sono famiglia
iniziamo su sprechi jobs co
ciao sono un po vj piacere che merda c'è
veramente una fine non lo so
va bene niente ragazzi siamo su sprechi
house la musica è andato a [ __ ] siamo
su sprechi house jobs ker mansion che
praticamente consiste nel superare varie
stanze arrivando alla fine vediamo
quanto riesco a fare ste pisodio daron 0
passiamo fruita da rom number one che
questa era difficile la room number one
di vista che lo finiamo in fretta sto
gioco se continua questa barca e va
cos'è porca [ __ ] eva le h
ma è un pezzo di cartone rafa frullo con
che effetto sonoro mi sono scagliato
addosso non è un certo punto in teoria
ragazzi dovrebbero esserci degli
spaventi ogni tanto tipo questi che mi
spuntano dai muri solo che la cosa
brutta ha visto già perché non te li
aspetti l'unico mio obiettivo è quello
di passare da una stanza all'altra non
mi aspetto che vi spuntino le cose in
faccia quindi insieme alla 21 ragazzi
prima o poi alla cento ci arrivo si
spera 20 23
dall aida trottola sono sempre dei
cartonati è però non me l'aspetto farsi
prendere dal panico da dei cartoni
disegnati meraviglioso fermi dello 0 7
sono son sono in ansia figli del diavolo
quanto ci scommettete che sfrutta
qualcosa adesso quanto ci scommettete
non è spuntato un cazzo mai scommettere
confavi j non sono capace io a fare
queste cose non conta se non sono in
grado di capire quando ci sono i jam
scherza tattico perfetto 50 sono
arrivato al 50 che cos'è sta roba
[Musica]
in un ascensore starò ma veramente mi
chiedo che stiamo andando negli inferi
fantastico non vedevo poco l'ora c'è una
porta salve dichiara residenti così
aperte con i primi residenti lo sapevano
così le porte che non è proprio un buon
segno è visto gioco di cui stiamo
parlando
perché io ho la barra della vita se qua
non puoi perdere vita mi spiegate questa
roba qui ha per caso cagato un
ectoplasma cos'è sta roba che disagio
migration durc round si no finalmente
qualcosa da fare era ora devo fare
qualcosa per andare avanti incredibile
spoting splashing sel king e in change e
simbel king mailing never stop the
shocking sei stato tu a cagare per terra
sei stato tu a cagare per terra
sono scappato non vi proseguire dietro
la porta vero giusto la barca veloce
veloce una semplicissima 63 quindi devo
andare no mi rallenta nostri cosi quindi
devo andare
ma veramente devo andare veloce prima
che mi raggiunga vasto stronzo trapassa
i muri non vale 65 carri corre il cazzo
e va bene non vale se ci sono il tuo
plasmi per terra non riesco a correre di
qua
ok
[Applauso]
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye veloce
però 68 che palle
sono fatta dai cazzo almeno la 79 a 70
ti prego fermati si è fermato non si è
formato vita musica si è fermato alla 71
ragazzi non ho idea del perché non ho
proprio la più pallida idea e perché ma
si è fermato va bene adesso capisco a
cosa serviva la vita però non ma neanche
toccato sto maniaco che siamo in
paradiso
gesù sei tu a osaka ho capito
perfettamente una 231 destra a [ __ ]
1234 che culo bellissimo non risolvo
puzzle dai tempi di prince of persia
ragazzi cos'è mister spock
no veramente ci posso giocare ma come
che sei un gioco nel gioco gioco nel
gioco ma no ma sono il fantasma sono
spooky ma perché pac man è fermo ma io
devo andare su pac man
[Musica]
la mia infanzia fottutamente rovinata ma
all of this book ma questi qua si sono
messi a fare dei minigiochi nel gioco ma
spiegatemi ma no ma no
ma cos'è e vabbè addirittura quant'altro
io li accoltello gli sfilò della testa
spiegate direi che basta sono contento
così proviamo l'ultimo non c'è un cazzo
nell'ultimo fantastico va bè ragazzi e
rom 75 lire che possiamo proseguire
siamo quasi alla cento quasi 7 don il
boss dei gatti è interno accesso
database questa roba
ma no ma come si fa vedere i fantasmi
vediamo se riesco a trovare il file del
mom ectoplasma di prima eccolo eccolo
psichica il tiering vediamo gli altri
come sono
ti infetta col morso quindi non devo
farmi mordere mica solo becco sono nei
casi o bellissima questa pinto
sappiamo quanto sono brutti mi devo
beccare mica tutti adesso è l'ultimo mi
ha dato errore l'ultimo non lo fa vedere
fantastico sì va bene va bene
l'ultimo è lui ma che cazzo stai facendo
va bene usciamo dal boss così almeno mi
vado a scontrare contro sta gente sono
proprio contentissimo non c'è un cazzo
la madre fa le torce quelle brutte prove
al 90 67
mancano tre stanze vi prego iddio non mi
fate fare figure di merda adesso cos'è
un cervello e dai tempi in cui sono nato
che lo cerco mita ecco dov'era finito 97
andiamo alla 98 ragazzi almeno ci
portiamo avanti mancano due non ci posso
credere
99 manca una tua madre tua madre lercia
lo sapevo che prima di arrivare al 100
dovevo prendermi fatto ma quanti
ascensori esistono il suo posto ma
quanto minchia sono contento di
prendermi jobs che era contento anche
lui come cazzo è che tra tutte le cose
che mi sono spuntate lui è l'unico che
non mi ha fatto paura e io soffro di
aracnofobia pke e anti aracnofobia costo
ragni porca eva cos'è sta roba quanto
brutto sto posto perche c'e la testa di
un dinosauro bellissimo piega lanciato
su rumore orribile una tessera di 75 sta
crescendo molto ma molto di più state
facendo crescere teste di dinosauro
fatemi capire a cosa mi serve st chiare
che ho preso
e uscito un soggetto bene fantastico
tornare indietro
veramente avanti ai believe in stage 5
is loose io leggo solo la prima riga poi
vado avanti chi cazzo è ceramica al
soggetto 5 che mi stava seguendo almeno
stava tentando di seguirmi cazzo e alien
ma cos'è sta roba
123 via via via via veloce ma quello è
il soggetto 5 sarebbe quella roba lì io
pensavo che comportate usare linosa ori
maledizione quindi preferisco dinosauri
ma basta basta il gioco della minkia
perché vide spuntare qualcosa di tre
secondi o siete contenti sono rispunta
qualcosa va bene ragazzi non temete
perché rientro a scuola sarà meno frutto
di questo
[Musica]
il cazzo capitano mi sono pagato a
questa c'è la gotta lei sara gentile
come ciao bambina gentile testa di culo
adesso sta diventando difficili siamo
bravi
ma tu chi cazzo sei via via via via via
via via veloce veloce vero non la passa
da forno a pasta la porta li mortacci mi
sa che sto a guardare barca [ __ ] bye
bye bye bye bye bye veloce però
[Musica]
la porta cambiar credevo che provenisse
da casa mia mi ero fermato perché
credevo fosse un sono in casa non so
perché qui appena ho realizzato che era
nel gioco mi ha preso fantastico cosa
vuoi
ciao ho detto ciao ciao hai dei problemi
che sto mostro qua stati fatti barca
[ __ ] si vede solo la torcia perché io
mi provo a guardarla c'è un problema di
fondo il tutto questo 175 vai scalda
però [ __ ] neanche colpito fino
adesso non credo di poterlo vedere le
morisse il cugino perché sei così lento
porca eva che problemi quanta il lungo
stop corridoio ad alti prego quanto ci
sta mettendo a superare un corridoio
minchia
oddio cela stai facendo ma non è che
sì infatti dove ero sbagliato strada ma
fa ancora mai fregato
era un corridoio senza fine mi chiedo
però non ora che andava avanti non stavo
capendo che invece sono finiti
va bene basta ragazzi miei è stato
alquanto strano e difficile soprattutto
non pensavo fosse così complicato ma
voglio da te sono io sono scemo prova
leggo la nato risponde sto cercando di
prendere tempo perché voglio vedere per
curiosità come continua solo vedere solo
vedere io concludo qui ragazzi spero che
video vi sia per cento ragazzi cose se
velocità suo commento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come
nevicata tale descrizione 120 vi siete
lì ci mettiamo il prossimo video dei
ragazzi